hello freak [ __ ] then they had a
weird line studio 54 had a huge line but
you got picked
studio 54 yeah yeah Studio 54 was on
fire you showed up and you didn't
guarantee to get in you got picked right
the way they do now in Hollywood like
they pick hot chicks right so they pick
hot chicks what was the thing we're
talking about one night they won't let a
guy in without a check something
yes I'm formula to go out in clubs and
yeah they never would let guys in
without chicks so if you walk into a
club with three guys they don't want you
they want the chicks in there first
yeah well the last thing you want is a
sausage fest look at all those dudes
trying to get in look at Stewart look at
this that was inside but outside their
deal are the people well that could be
it no that's outside that's outside
that's outside yeah what a zoo they just
try to get in just to try to get it what
was the big deal about studio 54 you
could snort coke dance get your dick
sucked and get your shoe shines all at
the same place and be home by 6:00
he was a vet you know I mean everybody
what they're like this is that Andy
Warhol it's Andy Warhol what was the
girl look uh she's got a beer bottle in
her mouth you know champagne on
champagne yeah
pretty odd [ __ ] Black Sabbath this one
54 look at Mick Jagger's wife dancing
with any Warhol look at Liza Minnelli
behind them Wow
so just like the place to be it was the
place to be you could go crazy
strange he strange times huh but here's
the beauty of it they have a station
like Sirius and it's called Studio 54
you could just put it on on Sunday
nights they do a podcast and what they
do is they interview people that
actually used to go there or work there
and I never tell you something John they
had a dentist on about a year ago and
his wife that it was crazy listening to
this interview about what their life was
they were professional dentist making
money in New York they stayed out till
5:00 6:00 every night well went home
took the kids to school went back home
took a nap too one got up went to the
dental office work till 5:00 went home
to another
fed the kids and at nine o'clock they'd
[ __ ] him bring the kids downstairs to
their moms and they do it all over again
five nights a week over and over and
then the lady was saying not till years
later Liza Minnelli thought I was a
publicist
she goes she didn't know I was a dentist
they just saw you in there we saw trust
funders you know that's all the people
who could do that type of [ __ ] do blow
till all hours of the night you could
put it out
they even had an interview about when
Bob home went to studio 54 Bob Hope I'm
hope walked into the studio that know
what the [ __ ] he was gonna wear he was
gonna walk into it he went out to the
middle of the floor and started dancing
and these chicks got together it's not a
time Bob Hope up just tying them around
like an Indian he's just in there like
laughing Bob Hope style don't you say
it's it's just a [ __ ] joke they just
left him there just tied him up and left
him there tons of stories on there like
that you know like just but then they
moved on but you got picked to go in
there
how did it move on like imagine how
weird it must have been when it finally
the door shut and that was it the people
where it was their whole life for years
people move on you know clubs get hot
different clubs I went that one time in
1983 maybe 84 it was done my friend he's
already done
he ever done it was just a bunch
[ __ ] trying to be cool Wow and I
phoned the hon dollar bill I was out of
money with a bag of blow no cash not a
dime in my pocket
can I look down the floor no more there
was a challah bone that's how I got
Saint that's how I got home Wow that was
it that's my studio 54 story it is weird
those clothes the nightclub scene the
nightclub scenes a very strange scene
and one club gets hot and then it dies
off and the people that are in that
business like try to figure out what
makes something hot and what doesn't you
got to rename places and redo them and
reopening and grand reopening and get
people to show up like I remember
hearing that they were paying Paris
Hilton like [ __ ] piles of money to just
show up at club that's it the
Kardashians and any of those people they
pay [ __ ]
you're there they take pictures and the
club gets hot
now after buddies start taking partners
it yeah shut up because you know it's on
the way down I'm so against you so after
a year some guy comes and I love your
place oh yeah I'll take care of ya and
that's how you get out of it or you do a
lot of people didn't they just like the
place on fire and stuff and scratch a
little Jewish lightning the play starts
to scratch you know I knew the guy that
owned the gay clubs in Houston like in
the 70s and he was telling me one time
he was you know once we got our you side
of him you light him on fire
like the insurance and then open up
another club that's it Jewish lightning
Jesus Christ
it's a weird scene you know I mean
people that just look forward to just
going out and just drinking and dancing
and snorting coke every night just
looking for like experience just
something different a while that takes
them out of their everyday grind and
just do it over and over and over and
over different like when I was growing
up it was Club area was big and the
rooftop you paid like twenty four bucks
to going at 11 o'clock and you drank all
night till 7:00 in the morning 24 bucks
or you could drink
it's [ __ ] booze I mean you're not
drinking kvass you ain't [ __ ] right when
you're doing blow you're just burning
that [ __ ] anyway you come out they give
you some sunglasses and that's it if you
went in after three was it was like 20
something after 11 and then like 17
bucks or you could drink after three so
seven in the [ __ ] morning and people
were packed that's what New York was
about back then it was just people
staying at those seven six New York is
what a four am glass call once last call
in New York I have no idea Florida I
think it's even later than New York
Florida Florida it closes for one hour
five o'clock at the News Cafe right
we're bullshitting we're having a good
time at five o'clock they'll come over
to you and say hey do me a favor
by five o'clock the bars on the close so
you can't ought to be until 6:00 so we
just ordered 25 beers
I can't wait to the ball pits a six and
now you [ __ ] ready to drink again I
got this for 1 hour 1 hour this was back
you know 20 years ago 15 years ago Negro
but a weird rule one out remember that
place we used to go to right down the
street from that improv yeah the Lou's
cafe yeah there's a great place right
place great breakfast great [ __ ] ball
the club went downhill hard though yeah
that Club in that place well the whole
Coconut Grove area became the only thing
that's still open to the dueling pianos
the pizza joint that more the dueling
piano places the slope yeah it's in that
little mall there with the movie theater
they always have those right next to
improv like they have one in Addison too
right Addison they have one up next to
Jon Lovitz up and Universal they do yeah
they used to if there's a [ __ ] I'm
going up there Miami has a 24-hour
really drinking now oh just Miami just
in the Miami entertainment district it
says oh well that makes sense it's 4:00
a.m. Broward County and Key West yeah a
little different everywhere else in
relators West Palm is where we always
worked
[Applause]
[Music]